do you plan to invite ben shapiro on
your show where do your political views
lay
that is the correct question is it crazy
to turn down a polyamorous lifestyle um
shave bald and wear a timple beanie at
300k
uh not a question good proposition
though i might dress up as malice for a
million you know he keeps on cosplaying
everyone
on their show i might dress as malice
what's happening people welcome back to
the show we hit 200 000 subscribers
which means it is time for another q a
episode
i pulled questions from youtube and
instagram
uh tried to filter out the ones that i
thought perhaps needed more professional
help than i can provide
but we will go through as many as i can
get through today let's get into it
what was the hardest podcast to prepare
for jordan peterson
by far he's a very easy guest to podcast
with but the problem is when you've
listened and watched so much of
someone's content
for years you have to try and synthesize
down all of the things that you've
wanted to ask them
for quite a long time into a single
single cohesive
episode and then he's got his book and
he's got obviously all the changes and
the
the stuff that he's been through over
the last couple of years so um yeah that
was
synthesizing everything i wanted to talk
about was difficult but i was so happy
with how that episode came out i felt so
proud and it it really touched a lot of
people so
yeah that was um it was worth the
challenge
best life hack to date speed up your
trackpad
if you increase your trackpad speed on
your macbook or your your windows
computer or whatever
just put it up to the maximum that it'll
go and you will immediately move around
the screen
10 to 20 quicker it's it's just such an
easy hack when i go on to other people's
computers now and i've got to scrape it
the mouse across the screen for hours to
get to the other corner
don't do that turn it up to the top
you'll fly around the screen for a
couple of days and then once you've got
it locked in
it'll be a new world for you least
satisfying part of the job as a podcast
host
editing now as much as i love the
conversations and listening back
listening back and trying to is the bass
right and recording the intros and doing
all that stuff soon there'll be an
editor that'll be able to master all of
the
episodes for me but at the moment that's
something
it's just it feels a bit laborious it's
the only bit of this job that feels like
a job
everything else just feels like fun are
you worried
being over 30 and single ah no
not at all i think this is the advantage
that men have that we don't really have
that biological clock which is ticking
along
uh that being said children aren't
totally disgusting to me now
up until a couple of years ago i just
didn't
really like kids at all they were just
loud and annoying and i live
not too far from a primary school so
they just woke me up if i'd been at work
in the nightclub the night before
um now i'm not doting right i'm not at
that stage but
children don't totally disgust me but no
i'm not worried about being over 30 and
single more women
had children over the age of 40 than
under the age of 20
last year in the uk um so if i
decide to have a child over 40 then
i can join that club uh how did you
learn to communicate
so clearly i heard peterson talking to
shapiro about this love from a
semi-recent subscriber well i love you
too
jason um yeah jordan brought me up on
ben's show
which was really uh kind and surprising
it was like a paid advert for me for two
minutes in the middle of the episode
but he was talking about the fact that i
try to i've tried over the last few
years to remove verbal tics and to be
precise with my speech
um how did i learn to do it was from
mostly through this podcast
you know when you do anything for three
or four hours a week
you're gonna get good at it you know if
you masturbated for three or four hours
a week you get pretty good at
masturbating after a few years
and speech is exactly the same also
being intentional with it you know i
want to
communicate concepts as succinctly as
possible
in an eradic manner i want to get what
is in my head out of my mouth
as plainly as i can to communicate it to
other people so you need to practice but
you need to be intentional with it
very often speech is just the thing that
gets in the way
of the thing that's in our brains
reaching the person that we're trying to
communicate it to so you can be lazy
with your speech in that manner
and i've tried to stop doing that but i
mean look at the the absolute titans of
this right look at the
ben shapiros of the world are the sam
harris's of the world these guys
are unbelievably precise so there's
there's levels to this game
but if you practice do it consistently
and you're intentional with the way that
you speak
you'll make gains congratulations and
i'm posting this in the spirit of
constructive feedback
i'm still disappointed at your light
touch interview with michael knowles for
example
not hearing you challenge him when he
said that alex jones was right about
almost everything
yeah the unfounded conspiracy theories
the government creating gays to reduce
population growth
his hiv conspiracy theories bad things
happen
when good people do or say nothing this
is a really
interesting insight and i appreciate
stuart i appreciate you bringing this up
um as a podcast host or as the host of
any sort of show like this
you need to pick your battles right i'm
having a conversation with michael
if i decide to interject every time that
he says something that i think needs to
be stress tested more
the conversation's never going to have a
central thrust it's constantly going to
be branching off
so i can hear him bring up something
that i disagree with to do with religion
or that i disagree
with to do with alex jones or anything
and if
every single time that that happens i
interject you're going to have this very
fragmented conversation
which actually isn't that enjoyable to
listen to and this is something that
even i as a podcast host needs to
remember when i'm listening to other
people's shows
oh i would have challenged him about
that you go well would you have done if
the end goal of this conversation is one
particular topic and you know that
that's a 10 minute or
20 minute detour to fully flesh out and
work out what's going on with this
you actually don't um yes stress testing
ideas
and propositions by guests is really
important because it gives them
more reputability right to the to the
audience
if you push a guest hard to really make
sure that they understand what they're
talking about and justify their position
on something especially something which
might be a little bit controversial
they either come out smelling of roses
because they've got a really robust
understanding or they crumble under
pressure and
they actually realize i need to reassess
if i can't communicate it
robustly i need to reassess my position
so it is a win
but as a guest sorry as a host you do
need to
pick your battles shave bald
and wear a timple beanie at 300k
uh not a question a good proposition
though i don't know whether
so i haven't reached out to tim yet
obviously malice is good buddies with
him
would i shave my head bald just for 300k
i'll probably do something fun for a
million i might dress up as malice for a
million you know he keeps on
comic con cosplaying everyone on their
show i might dress as malice
for a million we'll see i'll dress as
someone for a million maybe
uh congratulations chris you deserve
every success with your hard work thank
you
uh my question is you have openly and
honestly spoken about having depression
in the past
despite the suffering you endured at the
time is there a part of you
that is glad you have experienced this
uniquely human part of life
what would you say to and advise others
to do who are experiencing depression
what did you learn from it if anything
uh
yes it's a blessing and a curse to feel
things deeply
i wonder whether the insights that i
really value
that i've managed to glean from life
myself
i wonder whether they are the other side
of the coin
of suffering right that dread and or
are kind of the same or that um i guess
sadness is a depth of insight on one one
side but also curiosity is depth of
insight on another i'm not really too
sure but
this is i i i can't change the makeup
that i have right 50 of everything that
you are comes from your genes
in terms of your psychological makeup
and although we can
try and work around that and we can
create situations that are better for us
to exist in
we really are very much at the mercy of
what we were given when we
emerged into this world and with that in
mind you need to keep on working away at
stuff like that
um what would you say to and advise
others who are
experiencing depression more
of your mood than you think of is under
your control especially acutely
so get up on time
go for a walk get fresh air drink water
hydrate
train and speak to friends if you do
that if you're doing those things every
single day
and you're still suffering with a low
mood then there is a conversation to be
had
but if you are suffering with depression
and not looking after exercise sleep and
wake
hydration nutrition relationships if
you're not getting those things sorted
you're not giving yourself the best
chance to get out of that low mood in
any case
so really before you go and see a doctor
about something or a therapist
maybe not a therapist actually but um
certainly a doctor
to perhaps look at medicating your way
out of this if you haven't sorted the
base out at the bottom
i feel like you're putting the cart
before the horse uh what did you learn
from it
if anything man so much like all of the
traumas that we go through in life give
us
unbelievable insights and um yeah for me
just
the the depth of challenge that you can
come up with
simply through your own consciousness
right there can be ostensibly nothing
wrong
with life you can be you can have
nothing
going on there's no debt there's no
impending catastrophe and yet the sheer
weight
of existence can crush you and um
realizing that it makes you a lot more
empathetic to other people's struggles
uh but it also means that you have a lot
more faith in yourself
like when we're talking about critics i
heard rogan talk about this the other
day
he's saying he's such a a strong critic
of himself that when other critics
external critics that aren't within his
own mind say things to him he feels
bulletproof because he's like well what
do you think that you can say
that the best most proficient torturer
in my entire life
hasn't already said to me he's in a
monologue so it does make you very
bulletproof
but um yeah i'm more empathetic man like
people are going through challenges
even if there's nothing to be challenged
by uh
in quotes so yeah it's um
i wouldn't advise it as a personal
development strategy but
it works congratulations my question is
have you had the vaccine or are you
steering clear
what will you will you take him it uh
given what brett weinstein has been
discussing
dave the clips guy from dark horse
podcast clips that's brett's clip guy
um i've already had my first dose
of the vaccine this is the sort of for
some reason taking the vaccine
or not is also attached to political
views and
i haven't done a ton of digging into
this um
i appreciate that certain people believe
if you have taken the vaccine
that is some sort of a comment on your
worldview at large whether you trust big
pharma whether you trust big tech
whether you're going to be dictated to
by the man um but
to be honest i've taken a lot of party
drugs in my life and if the worst thing
that's gone into my body
isn't a bag from a random guy in a
nightclub toilet
it's a vaccine i'm going to be fairly
impressed that being said
i've committed to it because i like to
travel i want to be able to travel
realistically i can see restrictions
huge restrictions being placed on people
that haven't had
their vaccine and um you know if we're
all going down
if it is a way to reduce the fertility
of the entire human race to reduce
populations
then you know we're all in it together
there's a big club of us
so it'll be sweet but thank you dave i
love brett's show and i'm very glad that
you're a sub on this channel as well
uh congratulations i was wondering when
are you going to have sam harris on your
podcast
by the way enjoyed your talk with
michael knowles sam is next on the list
man like jordan was number one
numero uno and sam is definitely next up
every time that i listen to him talk
about consciousness or
the reality of our experience our normal
conscious experience of the world
he is at his absolute best he's such a
insightful guy
and you forget because he's it's such an
obvious thing to talk about you're
always looking for what's new and what's
cool
uh but sam's a beast i would love to
bring him on it'll happen
soon i said it'll it'll never happen
with jordan peterson and then
two years later it was sat down sat down
recording the episode
so give me time when are you releasing
your book recommendations
good question i am doing an e-book of
100 books to read before you die
and that should be completed
within a month or so if you want to know
when it's live go to chriswilex.com
lifehacks and you can sign up to my
mailing list there you'll be delivered
that as soon as it's live but yes chris
will x dot com
slash life hacks but i'll do i'll
probably do a video as well
about some of my top ones um that'll be
done soon it takes a while
fleshing out 100 books all of your
synthesis of why you like them and why
other people should read them
it's not a simple task do you plan to
invite ben shapiro on your show
yes i would love to he's got the
authoritarian moment
out now his new book uh i would love to
bring him on at some point
i i do think that
ben and matt walsh and some of the other
guys
the way that america's conservatives
talk about topics and the way that
british sort of center and center-right
people discuss topics is a little bit
different you don't really see
because it's so culturally and
politically bound to
their particular
world view right and also to the
situations that they've got going on
what's happening in the uk and what's
happening in america are actually quite
different at the moment
i brought this up with michael mallis
not long ago where we were talking about
how
uk conservatives are very different to
american conservatives
and most of the comments were people
saying well british conservatives are
more center
than they are right now and you go right
okay so we're not even when i say
conservative and when americans say
conservative
it's not even the same thing anymore so
yes
there is a there's an interesting
conversation to be had there
when two different groups of people say
the same thing but it means something
different
i think that's a really really
interesting question but yes
ben's a he is one of the most precise
deliverers
on the planet and i would love to have a
conversation with him at some point see
if see who ring
runs rings around who would you ever go
back on a tv program
to find love i think twice i think take
me out in love island
i don't think i can go on a third time
in all self
love and uh
without without just condemning myself
to a life of being a [ __ ] boy
i'm not convinced that i can go back on
uh also
the last i nearly got cancelled from my
tedx talk
for some of the stuff that's on the
youtube channel so
the depths that the uk media would dig
to
uh there would be too many clips of me
saying something that is just the sort
of thing that would get you pulled off a
off a tv show not that i really care but
if you're gonna
get yourself out there and you i don't
have any desire to be part of a council
culture
um catastrophe
my interest and my goal is to have
conversations that really engage me and
engage the people that listen to this
show and
other people that think like me and want
to improve their understanding of
themselves and the world around them
being some rabid sort of council culture
victim vanguard you know sort of at the
front being the guy that's the example
for everyone else to follow
maybe that'll happen down the line but i
don't i'm not seeking that
sometimes i feel like watching some
people on the internet
they're going out of their way to try
and find
scenarios that they can deposit
themselves into the middle of
so that they can be the cancelled guy or
girl
and um that doesn't really sound like
fun
to me getting caught up in that kind of
a drama doesn't seem like fun
uh plus yeah through i think two and
done
the old field tv shows where do your
political views lay
that is the correct question um
i don't think that you should be able to
put someone's or at least
most real thinkers shouldn't have their
political views
a a nice tidy neat box
you shouldn't be able to look at someone
and say because i know your view on
abortion i also know your view on gun
rights and immigration
and on tax and on whatever
it should be a multivariate very nuanced
viewpoint because
why i should take my views piecemeal
not wholesale right and um i
have some views that the centrist i have
some views that are on the right and i
have some views that are on the left
as i've got older i have noticed myself
start to skew more right
but so does everyone i said this to uh
michael knowles i think the other day
where they talk about every single time
that there's a general election
in the uk the same map where they
compare
under 25 voting habits to over
65 voting habits and you see that the
under-25s are very labor
and the over 75s or 65s are super
conservative
and you think who do you think that is
that that's you that's you in 30 or 40
years time
that's who you're going to be it's not
just like there was a wave of
conservatives that came through
65 years ago that were just born and
happened to genetically be conservatives
this is the path that everybody goes on
you start off
more open in terms of personality traits
jordan peterson says talks about this
and then as you get a little bit more
closed or your
openness starts to diminish a little bit
as you get older naturally because
that's what you do
you also have more wealth which means
that you're going to try and protect it
a little bit more
you also have more on the line with
regards to your family in the way that
they're treated
so people start tend to start on the
left and then skew toward the right
so having a
pre-fabricated set of beliefs
that neatly fit into a box to me is an
indicator
that someone hasn't been a very real
thinker like even
shapiro and michael knowles consistently
disagree
about nuances of stuff when they have
conversations on daily wire backstage
so yeah should be very very cautious
about anyone that you can
know one of their political views and
from it accurately predict everything
else that they believe
so mine mine lie across the board
uh what one value would you want to
teach your kids if you want any i do
want kids i would love
to be a father i can't wait to be a dad
um
i think the value of practice
and repetition uh i think that it was
something i didn't
really understand until i got a lot
older
so i played a lot of sports as a kid i
also did exams and stuff like that
but i didn't understand that skill
acquisition
doing a thing repetitively over and over
is contributing to your capacity when it
comes to game day and game day can be an
exam it can be an interview
it can be a sports match but i never was
taught the line the lineage that runs
between your practice
and your output and i think that it's
such a powerful concept to get your head
around that look
i'm not where i necessarily want to be
yet but if i work on a thing
hard if i deconstruct all of the
different talents that i need to do the
thing that i really want to do
and then i purpose them into little
iterative
games that i can continue to do over and
over
you actually end up in a place where
your capacity has increased
and it means that when it gets to game
day that you're an absolute beast now
so yes learn i would teach my kids the
value of practice and repetition
uh when i stumbled across modern wisdom
you had 70k subs my first thought was
well
where the hell has this guy been hiding
after listening to a few episodes it
became clear
to me that this quite simply is one of
the best podcasts on the planet thank
you
chris you're one of the most important
new voices in our culture the more
people that find you the better
fantastic i really that this is a
fantastic new review and i will use you
as my um
press manager when are you going to
write a book and what will it be about
i don't know i really don't know if i'm
built to write a book or not it's a
all of my buddies that have written
books especially coming from sort of
our kind of background not someone
that's a ryan holiday you know that's
been working under robert greene and
just a total freak when it comes to his
ability to create
long form written content
it's a traumatic journey
to go through ali abdal who i'm good
mates with is
you know he's one of the most productive
people he's like a professional
productivity person
and he's struggling to get through the
workload it's a challenge
especially if you hold yourself to high
standards which i do
so yeah um
it's down the line i don't know yet we
will wait and see
uh one question why is your channel
under your name
rather than modern wisdom which is what
i thought your channel was called until
i couldn't find it in my subs list i
honestly thought it was modern wisdom
with chris williamson well it's never
been that
uh it was modern wisdom yes correct um
but
i wanted to talk more about stuff that i
was interested in i wanted to do
more monologue videos like this talking
head stuff down the pipe
and also people were landing on the
podcast
on youtube and saying this is really
good but who's the interviewer
i'm like there is no way that you should
be landing on my show
and not know who i am so part of it was
to give me more latitude to be able to
do different bits of content if i do
want to do vlogs if i do want to do more
talking head style stuff and commentary
and the other half of it was just so
that i get more personal brand equity
pushed back toward me
but i don't refer to myself as modern
wisdom like alex o'connor right he
calls himself cosmic skeptic that's what
that's what he's called
it's a an alias that he works under that
was never called modern wisdom it was
just the name of the show
so yes it is now chris williamson and uh
no more name changes hopefully
your blurred background does or does not
contain
a totem pole i must know uh that is
that thing there i think that you're
referring to that is a vertical bookcase
which i got from connox uh some european
supplier and it's a seven foot
seven foot high ish vertical bookcase
you can stack books up
like that but there is a huge pile of
them just on the floor
uh because i now need another one
because the publishers continue sending
me out more books
how do you not become black pilled being
so close to this council
to this culture war cancer um
i don't get affected by the culture wars
stuff to be honest
um i enjoy discussing it and i think
that it's a fascinating insight into
human nature
but i'm not actually personally invested
that much i don't want untruths to be
spread
on the internet uh i don't want people
to
malign groups or
political parties or people with
particular beliefs or religions or
anything
um but i'm not
super invested emotionally
in the culture wars um i think this is
one of the
really important things that comes from
me not always discussing
whatever the next council culture pop
culture politics
issue of the day is you know i'm having
three conversations of personal
development or philosophy or insights or
a conversation with a porn star
for everyone that i have about politics
and
that gives me perspective and hopefully
you guys as well
right you're not just constantly being
fed by the modern wisdom podcaster by
chris williamson on youtube you're not
just constantly being fed this rabid
culture wars stuff
it's a broader worldview than that
because
it can feel especially if you're caught
up in the news cycle and if you enjoy
thinking about how this impacts our
culture and stuff like that
you can go down a really deep rabbit
hole that doesn't you don't ever
feel like there's anything else
happening
except for that but there is there are
more far far more books coming out
and bits of content being created and
interesting people
who talk about things that aren't
politics than are
and hopefully i continue to try and uh
bring those people to you so you can see
this as a
a nice vacation from culture wars
what's your number one tip for not
drinking alcohol
long term that is a good question
um i would say that picking an
end date is really important um
i found that it's easier for me to stick
to a
period of focus sobriety where i can go
monk mode and really work hard on myself
and
be productive if i know that there's a
an
end goal that i'm working toward even if
i then extend it so a couple of times
i've had a six month stint that i've
then
extended out okay well i'll do nine
months or a year or
18 months one of them ended up being but
not having an
end goal is just this open-ended really
difficult
to define challenge you don't know
when you're going to finish being sober
and that can cause you to lose
motivation
there was this uh study that i really
loved to cite where
they had two flights leaving dubai at
the same time one went to paris one went
to uh new york so the new york one was
about
six hours longer i think than the paris
flight but
all of the air hostesses that were
smokers who were on that they got them
to rate their cravings
from departure now what we would presume
is that because the flight going to new
york was longer
that their cravings would on both
flights would have tracked at the same
rate
and then the one that went to new york
would just continue to go up but that
wasn't what happened what they found
was that the length of time
before arrival was what
the cravings depended on so the
people flying to new york didn't even
notice that they had cravings
until a couple of hours before they
landed whereas the people going to paris
also didn't realize until a couple of
hours before they landed
but they'd only set off more recently
what it teaches us is that cravings
your next hit of whatever it is that
you're you're after
has far more to do with when the next
opportunity to get it is coming
than when the last time that you had it
was and with that in mind
having a goal that you work toward
knowing when it's going to be
helps with that right you can start to
regulate
your level of motivation and craving and
all that sort of stuff purpose
based on the target and also it lets you
say look i'm doing it for this time it
gives you a set point a flag in the
ground that you're moving toward
uh what advice would you give to someone
who finds it hard to discipline
themselves physically and mentally
what steps should they take what books
would you recommend
david goggins can't hurt me is pretty
good for this i think if you're
struggling to find discipline
um part of it is a habit setting
challenge right so it's a james clear
atomic habits
solution that you need to understand how
habits are made
and the process within which you can
build them
and i think the other half of it is just
giving yourself a kick up the ass
especially if it's a mental challenge
you know if you've got a physical and a
mental
struggle with discipline you just need
to see people that have been through
hell
and come out the other side so a david
goggins can't hurt me a ross edgely
the art of resilience also awesome man's
search for meaning by viktor frankl
or um the forgotten highlander by
aleister rouerkart these are
those two are both stories about men
that have been through awful prisoner of
war
um experiences and come out the other
side
not perfectly balanced humans but they
survived trauma that none of us can even
imagine
uh endurance by uh alfred lansing about
sir ernest shackleton's trip across the
arctic it's called endurance again
another story of just these
men who lived in the most brutal
conditions that you can imagine and they
made it through
and what it reminds you is that what
you're going through isn't that bad
that the capacity that you have inside
of yourself is so much greater than you
have
any idea it could be and you can tap
into that so i think it's a two-pronged
approach
right you get the atomic habits you
understand the habit setting and then
you get the sort of david goggins the
man search for meaning forgotten
highlander
alfred lansing type stuff and you
combine those two together you've got
the motivation that comes from the kick
of the ass and then you've got the
understanding that allows you to deploy
that motivation in a successful way
because
if you don't actually understand how
your habits are built
you're just kind of like throwing coal
onto a fire that's going nowhere just an
open fire as opposed
to directing it into something that's
going to actually funnel all of that
effort and get the most bang
for your book ah where are we
my question for you is how can you
separate that feeling of genuinely not
wanting to do a certain thing
versus conquering your inner [ __ ] it
feels like i cannot trust my own ego
this is a really cool question actually
um
yes it's very difficult we're such
self-deceptive creatures
right it's very difficult to work out
whether you're not doing a thing because
you genuinely don't want to do it or
because
you are falling short of standards that
you should
set yourself it's the same question that
people ask to do with training how hard
should i go when do i know
when stopping is because i'm falling
short of full effort
or i'm saving myself from getting
injured and
to be honest it's a it's a very
difficult line because you only know
when you've
crossed over it and gone too far when
you go too far
so i think it's an experience thing i
would also
say that making a plan in advance
and sticking to the plan as if it was a
boss that wrote it down for you
is a really good way to do it so
separate out the planning and the
execution
right the same as going for a run you
need to know how far you're going to run
now you can run a little bit more than
that but you need to know the minimum of
how far you're going to go on the run
because if you say okay
i'll start off on this you get two miles
in it sucks
everything hurts you haven't had your
second wind yet
you that's it you've just done it two
miles if you say i'm gonna do at least
five miles today that's your motivation
to get through
um so i would separate planning
and execution i think that's important
uh and then your execute
your executing uh situation should be
reliant on the planning one
so you should just treat it as if it's a
boss that said this is what you're doing
today
work through that and then see where
you're at if you can overshoot fantastic
but you don't need to if you're not
going to
uh where are we here
what kind of music do you listen to how
does your spotify look who are your
favorite artists um
so i'm basically a 2007 emo
that's been stuck in a time chamber
since then so i've still listened to a
lot
of bring me the horizon and memphis may
fire a lot of kind of like poser emo
post hardcore stuff
uh but then being a club promoter for
ages i love anjuna deep
anyone that needs new music to work to
just google the anjuna deep edition
a n j u n a deep and you nadeep
um it's phenomenal so i love deep house
melodic stuff
really sort of beautiful ethereal sounds
and then the other side of me
is kind of this uh latent emo
with a a died in quiff and a studded
star belt
um it's somewhere between the two
consistency or hard work which is more
important
um i
i think that a lot of the time
consistency can be hard work
and it's very difficult to do hard work
without it being consistent so i do
think that they're quite
similar i would prefer someone to be
consistent
than to work hard because consistency
works over a long period of time so it's
a long-term game
whereas hard work can cause you to burn
out so i would prioritize for
consistency
but i would also pat yourself on the
back if you are being consistent and say
i've worked hard because you have there
is no way you can be consistent without
working hard
i keep on dropping this stat about
podcasts that by getting to
the 21st episode of a show you're in the
top 1
of all podcasters ever that's
yeah it's going to take some hard work
to get there but the reason that you've
got to episode 21 is because of
consistency
less than hard work is it crazy to turn
down a polyamorous lifestyle
um i think it's quite crazy to accept
one
to be honest i think the people that
go non-monogamous or polly and make it
work
i am incredibly impressed by
because there is an awful lot
of genetic programming to stop you
from doing that as far as i can see like
permitting
the partner that you are invested in as
a man or a woman
slightly easier for a woman to let a man
do it
than it is for a man to let a woman do
it we're talking physical relationships
here
i i'm blown away by it i mean think
about aubry marcus
you know he was one of the guys that
popularized
polly non-monogamous relationships and
he explains about in his book where he's
the first time that his fiancee or his
missus at the time brings home another
man and he's
wretching on all fours in the middle of
the bathroom
and was adamant that this is uh
resistance that i need to overcome
does so and then is now happily married
to his new misses so i i think that
it is crazy to consider
a polyamorous lifestyle this starting
point
i would start at am i the sort of person
that can have a monogamous relationship
long term
if not what are the options down the
line but i
i don't know the whole poly thing to me
is um i don't know whether it's just
that i'm not built for it but
i would very much struggle to let
someone else
bang my misses and feel like well this
is fine because at least i get to bang
other people too
i feel like the discomfort would be
greater than the reward
in that situation what was the biggest
motivation to help start your journey
i was just sick of being someone that i
wasn't
impressed by i didn't like the person
that i was i didn't like the values that
i held
and i thought something needs to change
i was on this
tv show for a while and then came off
and
just thought what am i doing like is
this really the pinnacle of what i'm
supposed to
achieve and not that there's anything
wrong with that
being where you get to but i just felt
like i was built for something else
and um yeah not many people go on a
reality tv show to be
catapulted toward a life of integrity
and sort of higher calling
but i definitely was i think it'd be
interesting to know
who was the speaker you've had on the
show who had changed your mind about the
subject the most
that's interesting i mean a speaker that
i had on the show that changed my mind
before i spoke to him
was robert wright so he taught me that
humans are built to be effective not
happy
and this is an insight from evolutionary
psychology that being happy
isn't adaptive it doesn't help you
survive or reproduce
but even if you are made to be miserable
as a human being by your genetic
programming in the way that you're
forced to perform in your day-to-day
duties you can be
perfectly successful in terms of
evolution's eyes
and um that that insight that we're not
built to be happy were built to be
effective
helps you to understand that a certain
level of dissatisfaction
is a feature rather than a bug of
being a human and it helps us to reframe
when we feel dissatisfied or sad or down
or angry or frustrated or jealous or
anything that we don't want to feel
that stops being a bad emotion
it's not a bad emotion it's just built
in and you could say through
non-attachment if you were
going the buddhist route that there is
no such thing as a good or bad emotion
in any case
but for most people that aren't
enlightened you feel
attached to whether or not the way that
you feel day to day
is appropriate it's optimal it's
something that you wish that you could
have done
as opposed to something that you wish
you hadn't done and um
yeah just realizing that we're built to
be effective and effectiveness can often
make us miserable
so okay here is an emotion that i wish
that i wasn't feeling at the moment
that's fine like these will come they
will always come
how can we get through them how can we
deal with them more effectively than
last
time it's a much more equanimous way to
be to realize that happiness isn't the
default
dissatisfaction is congrats
congratulations were you always
interested in learning or when did that
develop
what are the tips for people who want to
speak as well as you do
so the speaking well thing um again
intentionality
and repetition just practice were you
always interested in learning or when
did that develop so i was in
uni for five years i did a masters a
bachelor's under masters
i was in full-time education for 18
years and i hated learning
like it was just a purely transactional
relationship for me
and i'm not super passionate about we
need to upend the the education system
bro
not yet at least i've got other insights
and interests i guess to get through
before that but i would definitely say
that the education system
didn't fully utilize my inherent
curiosity and perhaps even dampened it
down
so only when i was able to learn the
things that i chose to learn
did i actually get a passion for
learning even though i got to choose my
university degree but
as a lot of people you don't you don't
necessarily choose the thing that you're
interested in you choose the thing that
you think you can monetize once you've
got the qualification that it gives you
and yeah it just leads people the
problem with university is that
because it's a signal and a piece of
paper on the other end you're not
necessarily pursuing the thing that
you're going to be the best at or the
most interested at you're pursuing the
thing that you think
permits you to monetize it once you've
got the qualification which
can put people in in quite backward
situations and i would say so for me
but definitely the last sort of four or
five years i've just been
blown away with it feels like the
internet really did
you know turn a corner podcasts and
youtube and long-form content and
such a such a variety there isn't
essentially an endless number of
interesting people
that you can watch or read or listen to
now and um
no matter whether you are the sort of
person that can chew through books
you know again for me before because i'd
not read
ever non-fiction other than forcing it
down me to
just scrape through an exam at uni um
i wasn't able to go straight into
reading nonfiction and interesting deep
books that weren't super accessible i
needed the
front end of the funnel of you know a 30
episode series of jordan peterson
lectures or listening to joe rogan or
listening to a sam harris video because
that
got me thinking in the right kind of way
and that slowly brought me back in
i think a lot of the time these
superhuman
intellectuals that everybody gets
exposed to on the internet
they're so untouchable you know like
jordan was writing that maps of meaning
book for what
a decade two decades or something and
it's
so deep and it took you know it
literally took everything he had to do
it
who is supposed to be able to empathize
with that like who else is dedicating
two decades of their life to writing
one of the most deep or inspiring
insights into the world of jungian
psychology
you know no one else is doing that for
me i think i'd come at
this world of intellectual insight from
a much more normal place
just a guy that was partying and
drinking and kind of thought
is this all there is and then slowly
just thin end of the wedge what's the
what's the lowest investment
you know i remember the school of life
alanda bottoms
uh youtube channel there's some videos
on there that are three minutes long and
five minutes long
i used to listen to those or watch those
and reflect on them for a bit
and then over time you're like okay well
maybe i can get onto a 10 minute video
or maybe i can get onto
a 20 minute video or a podcast or maybe
i can do a podcast and then actually
write write a couple of things down as i
go through about what i really enjoyed
and
maybe i can read a blog post or maybe i
can start following some different
people on twitter
that's another life hack actually
unfollow as many people as you can
on twitter so i've got a limit now of 99
people i will not follow more than 99
people
at least for the time being and um it
just means that everything that i see on
my twitter feed is something that i want
they're not people that constantly
retweet memes and useless stuff
um and it's just such a nice place to be
that's a second life hack i should have
put that one in earlier
uh what are we
discovered your podcast after the jp
episode absolutely love your backstory
what would you say the top five pieces
of advice you would tell someone in
their early twenties
um
i would front load wealth acquisition so
i would get
wealthy as fast as possible that means
i would say purchase a house as quickly
as you can and
do not rack up debt credit card debt
um you can spend money when you're still
relatively young in your 30s and have
tons of assets underneath you
but if you do it the other way around
and you start buying fancy assets when
you're 22 years old and you've got no
wealth behind you
you're just putting off compounding
right i think
warren buffett has generated 95
of his wealth after his 65th birthday
because all of that time leading up to
them was just acquisition
you think he's the richest guy in the
planet but 95 percent of his wealth came
after he was 65 years old
so um front load wealth acquisition i
would avoid
developing bad habits once they're in
there they're in there right do not
practice what you don't want to become
i would develop a good health and
fitness routine one that you can stick
to for five to ten years time
find a sport or a training methodology
that speaks to you understand the basics
of nutrition
and just get into the rhythm of doing it
because you need this to carry you
through the next decade
um i would say yes to adventures
as much as you can but i would also this
is a two part one this is number four
and five yes to adventures and yes to
work
opportunities so i think that you need
to explore
more when you are younger and exploit
more when you are older
and the people that i know who are
the best exploiters in their 30s and 40s
are people that were explorers in their
20s
so they tried little things they started
a business here and they decided to do a
project there and maybe i'll begin a
blog and maybe i'll start a youtube
channel and
maybe i'll begin this partnership with a
friend helping him out with whatever it
is that he does
all of these are learning opportunities
that allow you to zero in on where
your value is and i was very fortunate
that i got exposed to
so much in nightlife accounts marketing
finance customer interactions b to b
b to c uh hr everything full works right
and it means that i can go okay i'm good
at this i suck at this i'm good at this
i suck at this
without that experience how do you know
you just don't you
come into the world with all of these
presumptions or you know stories that
your parents told you
about how you were a people person or
not or good at maths or not
and you never stress test that if you're
not doing stuff
so yes i can't remember the five but
those are
five uh wasn't it like yesterday that
you reached 100k
congrats chris your work is valuable and
much needed thank you
as for a question do you have any
recommendations for a book about
financial planning debt
student loan management yes i do
morgan households the psychology of
money as far as i'm concerned that's
really the only book on finance that you
need
uh debt student loan management
student loan management i don't even
know how you manage it they just tell
you that you need to take money
out of your wage if you're not
self-employed uh
debt management i would just avoid it
and pay it off as quickly as possible
um video guiding perfect example of this
had needed to use his credit card last
year
and as we started racking up some more
money on the show as i
cool dude the first place that this
needs to go is not into you buying
anything
it's into you buying back your freedom
from the debt that you'd accrued
uh and that wasn't you know i wasn't
even paying interest on it but i was
like you know in however many months
time six months time you're going to be
paying x number of pounds per month on
this
so i would get out of debt as fast as
possible and then in terms of financial
planning
morgan households the psychology of
money uh robert kiyosaki rich dad poor
dad is also
pretty good and the navalmenak so
almanac of naval ravicant by eric
jorgensen
is great a little bit less immediately
applicable that's more about wealth
acquisition
but yeah those are three really good
ones
how many episodes have you recorded but
never released
so i i think it's about seven
now out of 330
or so so it's like a two percent failure
rate
which i'll take i reckon that's not too
bad and the only times that i don't ever
release them are just if they reflect
poorly on the guest
you know if uh the guest has come on and
had a particularly bad day
or doesn't communicate their ideas
tremendously well
it doesn't make for a fantastic
listening experience for the audience
and as the platform grows you know
a couple of hundred thousand to a couple
of million people a month listening to
something
you need to have a standard that the
guests meet
and if they don't meet it then you know
unfortunately that
maybe they can come back on in in a
couple of years time and and see if
they've
changed their delivery method or maybe
they just had a bad day um but
if you're going to put someone out to
reach a couple of hundred thousand
people you need to be sure that it's
going to reflect well on them as well
because a lot of the time this is a
relationship that i've got with a
publisher or maybe even the person
personally and if
if they weren't on form like cutting an
app and cutting an interview is
something that i we never do we almost
never do it apart from dropouts
and people coughing and sneezing and
like the gas man walking in and stuff
like that
we don't do it because of someone's
performance there but if their global
performance within
the entire episode is poor i just don't
think it's a
i don't think it's very good it's not
good for the audience it's not good for
me and my platform and it's not good for
the guest so why would you why would you
put it out
have you ever changed your opinion due
to an interview
literally every single time that i speak
to someone
every single time that i do strong
opinions loosely held
not loose opinions strongly held that's
what every single interview that i do
feels like
and i think being exposed to it and
hopefully for you guys as well listening
to it
we're constantly speaking to people
about topics that you've never even
really considered your opinion on before
like what what is your opinion about the
mindset of elite athletes
what is your opinion about trans rights
within
sport or what is your opinion on whether
or not we live in a simulation
every single episode you are getting
your world views stress tested along
with me and you hear the
challenge and the discomfort and the
total ignorance that i have because i
don't know
i i've got an idea about what i think
and then you speak to an expert and
you're like oh my god that's that's
fairly compelling i'm going to have to
reassess my world view
so every single episode i
i get my opinion changed and i think
it's a very very good thing for everyone
to have
happen how could i get a session with dr
peterson
for real though i get trauma zone outs
uh
the number this is a bizarre side effect
of doing an episode with
uh jordan that the number of people that
try and get in touch with him
via you i have an article that i've
written for him i have a
a a video that he needs to see i have
this this concept that he he has to
learn about
i need to get a message to him um it's
obviously flattering for him because
these people had
been so touched by his work that they're
desperate to get in touch with him that
being said i'm
it's not like i'm no longer i'm not his
pa
right i'm not sending him carrier
pigeons to do stuff uh for real though i
get trauma zone out
adam lane smith at the brometheus on
twitter
he came on the show he uh is a
specialist
in trauma he's a trauma counselor and
i'm sure that if you spoke to him
um he may be able to either work with
you himself or
he might be able to get someone who can
if not
better betterhelp.com modern wisdom 10
off with your first month
uh congratulations bro i found out about
you in the modern world some podcasts
only like three months ago but you have
brought such an incredible amount of
change into my life for that i'm forever
grateful my question is other than the
obvious one love island era what has
been the biggest inflection point in
your life so far
i'm not too good at formulating the
question but i'm sure you get me you
know
that moment in life being honest it was
that one it was
being on love island surrounded by
people
who are full-time
extroverting party boys and party girls
and going
i thought this was me this is this is
the situation
and i thought these were my people and
i've got nothing to talk to them about
i can't i can't hold a conversation i
feel like i felt like a black sheep
in that situation and um that was it it
was it was a
dose of contrast so refined
and so nuclear grade that i couldn't
ignore it anymore
um so it was really useful but other
ones uh another big inflection point was
rupturing my achilles last year so that
really sort of made me think okay so
what do i value in myself you know as a
model
and a young guy that was a club promoter
for a long time
my looks were a big part of um i still
are a big part of kind of my appeal and
what i
valued in me but when you can't train
anymore and when you sat on the couch
and you're on opiates to deal with
having the back of your leg opened up
and pulled back together as sutured back
together in
you know a moderately intense mechanical
surgery you can't really rely on that
anymore and it reminded me again that
looking at developing capacities that
are scalable and work
long term over time that isn't just the
way that you look and this is something
that i think all girls need to
really really try and remember if
you get to 30 years old and you are
still utilizing your looks as the
primary source of value that you bring
to the world
you are heading for to become a
depreciating asset
and it's harsh to say but you need to
have something
which is going to work long term for the
rest of your life
what's it going to be is it going to be
how loyal you are how caring you are
your insight
your ability to look after other people
your ability to help other people your
ability to
help yourself it can't be your looks
because your looks are only going
in one direction they're not going in
they're not going in
they're not going to increase no ones
are you know very very few people
very few people get fitter after the age
of 35
right so if you are
still relying on your looks it's it's a
very dangerous position to be in
and that was what the rupture taught me
it was like look you can't rely on this
anymore
you need to make sure that you're happy
and you're able to add value
in other ways because what happens if
your looks get taken away what happens
if you can't train for
four months which is what happened how
do you feel then do you still have value
do you feel like you're
still worth something in the world and i
did and that was really nice that was a
nice realization
but if i hadn't had the podcast if it's
still being love island chris
i did i don't know whether i don't know
whether i would have had that
so yeah i'm very glad about that what an
accomplishment
but what a constant gift you give thank
you i followed you for two years under a
former account name a blessing my
question how do you manage
yourself emotionally when you are worn
tired beat down or otherwise spent
around the politically triggered and
aggressive
i find it hard in social settings
sometimes and with people who distribute
harmful lies
or even vicious manipulations of the
truth yet again this is kind of like the
um
not getting black-pilled thing right
if you are very very heavily invested
in the direction of the culture wars
i can imagine that it's a you're getting
ragged around as the culture gets ragged
around
right you know you will have whiplash
from the whiplash that comes out of the
media because
there's flip-flopping around all sorts
of policies and it's very very extreme
and the language is super super
inflammatory
um i would say have strong opinions
loosely held
you know don't invest yourself
personally
into a particular position too much
because
at the moment you are you are going to
be suffering
orders of magnitude more because of
where the culture's at
at the moment this doesn't mean that you
don't care about stuff or you can't have
causes that you genuinely believe in
but pick your battles right don't
believe in everything
because i i do sometimes think that the
people who
are concerned about culture are just
concerned about it wholesale across the
board
as opposed to okay what are the things
that you really really want to care
about
or else if you do care about everything
that's a weakness because you're going
to
be at the mercy you're going to be so
ruthlessly pulled about by
the vicissitudes of the the tide that
comes in and out with
media legacy media manipulation of the
truth all that sort of stuff at the
moment
pick your battles uh question who's a
guest that changed your thinking most
deeply
slash sustainably um
so said robert wright he was a big one
aubry marcus
was you know he's nearly two years ago
now and the guy is such a beast i
thought
he was just uh this sort of psychedelic
warrior dude who'd got first mover
advantage and was mates with rogan and
done whatever and i'd listen to his show
and i thought he was really
competent but you never know it's like
watching
it's the same reason that people find it
interesting to debate about who's gonna
win fights
right you can watch someone else fight
other people
but until you've seen them fight you or
fight your guy you don't know because
you haven't stress tested them
as directly as you can and it was the
same with aubrey
um him saying you do not serve people
from your cup you serve them from the
saucer that overflows around your cup
and the ego is incapable or the persona
is incapable of receiving love it can
only receive praise
those two quotes have still stuck with
me two years later i can still remember
him saying them i remember where he was
sat i remember the way he looked i
remember what i thought
stuff like that it makes the hairs on
the back of your neck stand up you're
having these conversations with people
and the penny drops and they've done it
it was because of them because of an
insight that they've gleaned and now
you've got it
it's crazy it's crazy the way that it
happens
my question is given your success as an
interviewer self-help guru in your own
right
and an abnormal human being all around
what has been your biggest struggle that
you have yet to find a way to mitigate
your satisfaction i
am not a self-help guru adam thank you
it's very kind but
i'm such an idiot at all of this stuff i
have podcast smarts right so i've got a
couple of lines that i can say
about a few different things but it goes
no deeper than that for the most part
apart from in a couple of
very very narrow domains um the biggest
struggle for me
is probably uh
the same one actually that rogan has um
which is being too harsh on yourself all
of the different
issues that you come up against the
conversation that you have you
trip up a word or you start to say and
then sorry no that one and you move in a
different direction or you
accidentally stumble over a particular
pronunciation or you forget a quote that
you really thought would be interesting
it's so hard to let go of that because
you're just constantly ruminating about
i could have done that i should have
said that
you have an interaction with someone and
then as you go and say goodbye you say
see you instead of saying goodbye why
did i say see you maybe i should have
said goodbye
maybe i need to find a course about how
to teach me about how to say goodbye
and it just kind of doesn't really stop
um it's good because it pushes you to be
as much as you can be right it pushes
you to constantly be working on your
craft
but the discomfort of that is associated
you know how far you are all the time
the reason that you're good is because
you are
checking where could i have been and
where did i get to and what's the gap
between those two things and how can i
start to close that more and more and
more
and there's a very very small number of
people i think that have that
world view where they want to be all
that they can be but don't lambast
themselves when they don't meet it
um that is a a very unique human they
will be out there but it's not me so
yeah i need to
and it's assisted to be honest it's
assisted very much by you guys
by hearing people give me support
on this show it makes me feel good right
it makes me think yes like i'm doing it
it's really really adding value to
people's lives because it i didn't have
that before
you know no one went into one of my club
nights had some jaeger bombs and came
out and told me how profoundly it
impacted their life but
it does happen with this show and um
yeah that that helps me to say okay
maybe
maybe there's still headroom above what
you could be doing
with speech with insights with research
with guests with
work rate with productivity with
whatever it might be but you
you're doing okay you're doing okay and
that's that's really nice
actually uh my question is what are some
advices
advises what are some advises uh you'd
give to someone in their 20s and some
good habits to be doing from your
experiences
so the five that i gave earlier on i
really think
not building bad habits when you're
young is super important do not
practice what you don't want to become
because once you lay down that myelin
right once you've got those neural
networks put in
they don't go away this awesome story
this uh
girl 16 years old started horse riding
and
her and her friends used to smoke while
they were horse riding
because that's when their parents
weren't watching them so they could
smoke and then come back and it would be
all hidden by the smell of the horses
and her mum wouldn't know and then she
stops horse riding when she has a kid
10 years later her daughter is 10 years
old
and she wants to start horse riding with
her daughter because she thinks this
would be a beautiful thing for mother
and daughter to do together
gets on the horse immediately wants a
cigarette for the first time in 10 years
because she has associated the act of
riding a horse with smoking a cigarette
and that's what everything is like you
have triggers you have responses but
they do not go away
don't practice what you do not want to
become you don't get to pick
to not lay down a habit you just get to
pick which habit you want to lay down
and with that in mind you need to be
incredibly careful
about what it is that you're spending
your time doing what behaviors you're
embedding
because if you're not careful you can
push yourself into a cul-de-sac
that essentially you're always going to
be able to go back down
um where are we here what are the most
profitable ways to be investing 10 000
preferably by rate percentages to be
invested for generating more
sources of future income um
personally for me i am a huge fan of
property
i just bought my fifth house and i
am a huge huge proponent of
getting out of the renting game and
purchasing a property
which you can live in and which can
generate your revenue so ideally you
want
three lettable rooms one of which can be
yours another two can be to housemates
and you will essentially live for free
if you can do that now
you probably need a little bit more than
ten thousand dollars you need about
around about 25 uh in the uk if you want
to get a 20
25 loan to value ltv uh mortgage
so you might need 30 grand
which isn't an insignificant amount of
money but if you can do it and if you
can do it young
it will make such a profound change to
the way that your finances are set up
you're no longer paying money into
someone else's mortgage you're paying
your own
and it's appreciating in capital value
and
other people that are staying in the
rooms are also paying you for it's such
a game changer
unbelievable game changer if you could
go back 10 years and give yourself
advice what would it be
buy bitcoin obviously who who else who
else doesn't want to have put 10 grand
into bitcoin 10 years ago
buy bitcoin huddle sell whatever it was
end of april sell just before elon musk
tweets new sweet
uh which hard truth if only do you wish
that you'd never come to learn and
stayed ignorant to
this is someone who knows the show very
well i love harsh truths uncomfortable
insights about
human nature um i don't there's none
i've never learned anything that i wish
i'd stayed ignorant to
the choice in life is between becoming
aware
of the afflictions that are associated
with it
or the discomfort of being ruled by them
for me there is no red pill that you
shouldn't swallow like all of them you
should know
everything you should just be gobbling
them up like
uh what did mario ride
what was that thing that big turtle
whatever him him gobbling them up like
him uh
because the more insights that you have
the more that you can start to account
for the way that your brain works
and the way that the world works and the
way that cognitive biases and other
people work
and everything so there's none there are
none that i wish that i'd stayed
ignorant to
have you met new friends through doing
the podcast yes
tons malice obviously really
like a unbelievably close mate now
morgan housel douglas murray
like uh andrew doyle sargon like these
are people that
you message for just
for crack for it doesn't have to be
about anything how's your day going
how's your week go oh i saw you done
this thing recently
and um they're incredibly different
people as well
you know like there isn't really a
single like what what does
malice what do malice and me have in
common essentially nothing other than
the fact that we both
are in this creator space um
yes it's one of the best things you know
and the same goes for
if you're thinking i'm really struggling
to find people that i resonate with
just try producing content
around whatever your biggest interests
are because other people
that are also interested in that will
gravitate toward you and before you know
it you will have a
huge network of people who are all on
the same path
who hold similar values to you that care
about similar things
uh yeah it's phenomenal how often do you
get recognized in real life
uh well i haven't been out of the house
a massive amount over the last year
obviously because i've covered but
moderately it's no longer about love
island which is nice but i look a bit
different to how i did when i was on
love island um
it's a couple of times a day or whatever
especially in newcastle because it's
the podcast still got quite a big
following up here
um a few times but it's always nice
stuff i've never had
and this is um i can't remember who said
this it might be nicole arbour
but haters never say it to your face i'm
sure there are people out there
even in this city that would love to
tell me what they think of me but
they never do so you get a very
disproportionate
experience of the people that come up
and say things to you
it's the only people that come up and
speak to you are the ones that have nice
stuff to say
which means that you can probably grow
an ego pretty quick but it's also really
nice
lovely experience how often do you read
uh about 15 minutes every morning and
maybe 15 to 30 minutes every night
it's not much i really still
struggle especially with recall uh i
just
you read a thing you read 15 minutes and
you try and get you know one concept
out of what you've just read you try and
recall it i'm not
some unbelievable second brain personal
knowledge management
system guy i think i have to pick my
battles and um
one of the battles is not creating a
beautiful index of every book that i've
ever read i really wish that i did
that would it would make me incredibly
happy but
i just don't think i'm built that way
and i've tried and it doesn't work
so i just read and then the good [ __ ]
sticks and right now i am reading
uh enlightenment the damndest thing by
jed mckenna and it is
awesome would you ever go into politics
no way i i do not have the temperament
for it
i am far too
quick to call out the elephant in the
room which i think there's a there's a
big element of game playing
in politics right where there's beyond
the pure formalities of the way that the
debates and the discussions
occur um the level of bureaucracy means
that there's so
much game playing there's so many
structures that you need to stick to
whereas i think the advantage that you
have
from doing this sort of stuff is you
find
the obvious but
as yet unnoticed elephant in the room
he said why is that there and everyone
goes [ __ ] yeah why is that there
but if you do that in politics that
compulsion for curiosity i think is just
gonna get you into trouble
and i've partied a lot you know
if if someone wanted to dig deep into my
history as a
professional politician i i think i
would be
in in trouble but barack obama did blow
right so
did a bit of blow uh so maybe i'll be
fine
how much did academic education
contribute to your current success
uh almost none not at all um
i found good friends at university
and i learned a lot through building my
business at university
but learned essentially nothing while i
was there
do you think the focus on a person's
race in the media
is making people more racist yes yes i
do
i think that constantly talking about
whiteness or blackness or bme people
or bain people or it is
pushing polarization in a way that is
very very unhelpful
i i don't see why anyone that wants to
reduce racism would put race
at the front of their discussion over
and over again this isn't to say that
you can't have discussions about race
but when the first thing that is brought
up
about a particular situation is the race
of the person that was involved in it
i i don't understand how that helps
anyone i don't think it does
how do you get influential people to be
your friends at a young age
this is a really good question um
because
for a long time i've been in a situation
where what i've done
has been beyond the age that i was at so
i was a club me and my business partner
were club promoters young
you know 18 19 20 21 and we were going
and sitting down in meetings with the
directors of huge leisure companies
worth multi-million
pounds and we were just these two kids
you know you've got 20 year olds sat in
front of you
saying you need to seriously negotiate
with me
or you need to look and deal with me on
a level
as opposed to like someone's just
brought their
nephew into work day um
similarly in the podcasting space most
people that do this
are really like i'm at the young end of
this at sort of 33 years old
up to you get to toward the absolute top
of the game when you're around about 50
because you have more life experience
and your delivery is more
accurate and your network effect means
that you've got better access
um it's a challenge okay
being beyond the curve with regards to
your age is always going to be a
challenge
the way that i would advise you to get
influential people to be your friends
is to do something that puts you around
people who are influential
so you can't just for instance
if you enter into an interaction with
someone
and you have something to offer
seriously have something to offer them
they're not going to turn you down no
matter how old you are you can be a
two-year-old
but if you're a two-year-old who happens
to know elon musk or
happens to be really really smart at
programming or whatever your chosen
field is
people aren't going to turn you away so
i would be
more concerned about developing the sort
of talents
and abilities and cultivating the kind
of networks
that people who are influential people
will want to be associated with
as opposed to worrying about your age
also remember that there are influential
people
that are at your age and in 10 years
time those are going to be the really
influential people that you look up to
now
so yes would it be good to jump the
queue and be able to
latch on to someone that's compounded on
network effects for another 10 years
yes but don't forget the ones that are
with you now are going to be those
people in 10 years time
so look around you who are the people
that you would invest your money in
if all of your friends with a stock
market all the people that you know on
the internet were a stock market
who are the people that are your age
that you would put a grand in now
because you think that they're going to
go to the moon in 10 years time find
them
speak to them how many friends have you
lost
by having a conservative view um i only
have a conservative view on certain
topics but i'm more outspoken
around being critical of cancer culture
as far as i can see
almost none i i don't think that i've
lost
any uh that's not necessarily because
i don't have views that by some people
are seen as something they disagree with
but i think that if you show you're a
good faith actor
if you show that you're coming at this
not as someone that's made a knee-jerk
reaction but it's a considered viewpoint
strong opinion loosely held if you come
in to an interaction with that
i don't think that anyone can see you as
anything other than a good faith actor
this is his position maybe i disagree
with it but i understand why he
understands it
and i understand that he's not just
ruthlessly blindly passionate to it
he's prepared to change his mind maybe
that's my job to do it
so basically none and um
if anyone did i mean if someone decides
to no longer be friends with you because
of your political viewpoint
i don't think that they were a real
friend
that is it there are so many questions
that i didn't have time to get to but
it was what four months since the last
one so it could be
share the episodes more if your question
didn't get answered share the episodes a
bit more drive me some more subs and in
a couple of months time i will do it
again for real though
thank you so much um this show is
everything to me it's so rewarding and
the fact that you guys are here the most
radically
sensible unbelievably insightful
audience on the internet
uh i will have your babies i thank you
very much
and i'll see you next time thank you
very much for tuning in
if you enjoyed that then press here for
a selection of the best clips
from the podcast over the last few weeks
and don't forget to subscribe
it makes me very happy peace